اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تدميرا مسيره
اوكرانيه كانت تحاول مهاجمه منشات في
مقاطعه موسكو واكدت الوزاره عدم تسجيل
اضرار بشريه او ماديه في غضون ذلك قالت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه اطلقت ثلاثه صواريخ ونفذت 29 غاره
جويه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه كما اطلقت
اكثر من سبعين قذيفه من راجمات الصواريخ
خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه
واضافت الهيئه ان قواتها سيطرت على قريه
تيستاروما بمقاطعه دونياتك وتصدت لمحاولات
تقدم من روسيه في المقاطعه نفسها بينما
نفذت القوات الاوكرانيه هجوما على محورين
في مقاطعه
بدورها قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
هنا مليار ان قوات بلادها حققت تقدما جنوب
مدينه بخموت في مقاطعه دونيتسك كما تقدمت
وحدات من القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا
فيماسك في مقاطعه
اما في المناطق الشماليه للمدينه فتصدت
قواتنا لهجمات العدو وفي اتجاه كوبيان
يحاول الجيش الروسي اشغال قواتنا عن
معاركنا الناجحه في بخمر ويهدف دون جدول
اجبار قوه على التراجع من المرتفعات التي
تسيطر عليها وفي الاتجاهات الجنوبيه
وتحديدا في ميليتو بولديان تحقق تقدما
ايضا المهم الان هو ضرب قدره العدو على
المقاومه
فالمقابل اعلنت القوات الروسيه صدى هجوم
للقوات الاوكرانيه بالقرب من الرابطين
عدد من الاليات العسكريه التي دفعتها
اوكرانيا لارض المعركه ذكرى الجيش الروسي
في بيان نشرته وزاره الدفاع ان مدفعيته
واصلت قصف مواقع عرض القوات الاوكرانيه في
سفيرسك بالقرب من بخموت كما تشهد منطقه
بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه حيث يقوم
اللواء الخامس في فيلق جيش دونيتس
باستهداف مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه
بالمدفعيه